after us what's it like working one of
the best looking shows on TV in that
it's got one of the best looking casts
on TV um you know it feels pretty darn
good actually I'm looking at all the
beautiful people on our set and our crew
is actually pretty good-looking too so
yeah it's all about a blessing really
yeah that's but it's accidental what's
it been like so obviously John Barrowman
has come on in season 3 as a series
regular use it on before and how's that
been like for you working with him and
all you guys as well because his role
has kind of expanded a lot and you've
had a lot to work with the season with
him working with John is probably my
favorite but it's probably the crews
least favorite because you're the least
amount of work done
um but yeah it's it's a world when
having him on side it's the best yeah
for me he just changes up the energy of
the air it just becomes like we're in
grade school having funny he's like he's
like we have a lot of fun to work with
him like like he's singing and dance you
know like entertain like even if you
like if you're not shooting so that's
great what did he think about that kind
of big reveal then at the end with him
being now in the place of resin to play
his daughter
I mean um but yeah it was pretty pretty
awesome to say the least
but not make you add to the demons so
you could become one the next we're all
so cool as well I actually never even
thought about that
whoa bomb dropped um who knows I mean
all I can think of right now is that
Thea is just trying to figure out what's
happening to her or not happening to her
since she has been resurrected from the
Lazarus but no characters and really
expanded the season and I've seen you
killed Sarah Keys character and now that
she's coming back they're legends of
tomorrow yeah could we see your
character maybe go across to that Shore
and see that she's alive intuitive it
the guilt away from you I mean with the
all the series that have come out of
arrow from the flash - now legends - I
mean there's probably gonna be an
infinite number of more eventually
there's all that possibility just
wrapped into it it's the reason why
we've been able to do that and it makes
it so there's just so many options of
what could happen along those lines I
can't say anything for sure because I
honestly don't even know the true actual
answer but there's always hopes and
options out there really how long do you
think arrow can run for we're about to
go into season four and what do you
think he'll stay for the long haul
if Thea survives I mean I hope she
survives I think I think a month yeah I
come back to life once already and I
think that once you know she got her
pursuit I think that might have
solidified her a bit which it feels
really nice but yeah I would happily
stay a part of the show and I think
about everybody would we were all a
pretty happy family we think we have
luck the heck out working with each
other I wrote was a very action driven
show so very physically the morning how
is it like to kind of cope with that
like the hardcore action stuff you guys
go well we have amazing stunt doubles
incredible incredible stunt doubles and
in shirts clauses written into our
contracts and make it so we can't do a
huge chunk of the stuff that even some
of us want to but it's definitely a
physical challenge at all times to keep
up and to to make it look like we can
you know move fluidly in between the
little cuts that we do get to do as well
as looking like we can actually are in
physical enough shape to pull this stuff
off because you know if you got a flab
sticking out your belly you wouldn't
think that something's gonna punch it
it'd be a rocker I think I think that
the action actually the physical stuff
is the easiest part compared to the
emotional yeah stuff you know having to
go there it's like it's it's after doing
an emotional after doing a physical
scene I'm good I could do that all day
but after doing one of these emotionally
psychologically meaty scenes I'm pretty
drained well you've had a very emotional
season of see the character lost the Sun
and everything like that and you won't
used to have only had one season
baguette was to like your characters and
look the characters was that tough or
scary think you've got one season to do
this
I didn't even think about that I was
just thinking an episode by episode but
every single every single episode you
know you just try to give as truthful a
performance as possible and yeah they
gave us all a lot of very challenging
psychologically and mentally emotionally
challenging moments focusing on my
element what was it like in the final
scenes with first youselves characters
on one yourself has got the Moscow
katana Ronin yourself they're fighting
against each other you know for me when
I heard the news that Masayo was gonna
go at the hands of katana
I mean I thought I thought that was
brilliant I thought that you know I'm a
huge Shakespeare fan and the reason why
I love this show because it parallels
the the profound depth of you know
Shakespeare and you know that's
something that happens so yeah for me it
was it was pretty cool when I heard
about it I was I mean I knew it's gonna
happen someday but I had a feeling it's
gonna it's gonna come in but I was like
I was really sad and like on on the set
I was a bit upset before I'm actually
yeah it was such as any possible if used
to appear in next season I'll see your
characters dead but there's always that
flashback opportunity and you're still
alive luckily so you can go along so is
to be in any talks about next season
appearin mark has told me don't make any
plans I'm like oh great I'm gonna you
know I think it's well first off when he
called me to tell me about the fact that
Masayo was gonna die before oops
spoiler was gonna go before the end of
the season will by the finale he just
seemed real nervous and apprehensive I
was talking to me and I was like hey man
you know I get the sense that your your
little nervous sharing this information
with me you know I'm just a huge fan of
the story of the show itself and the
fact that it's been going on this long
my character has gone on this long was
just was just a surprise so I knew at
some point this was going to happen and
he says I said well you know like you I
could use a vacation
so this is good news for the story and
my vacation he says well don't make any
plans obviously all of you now like
immerse yourself in the world of arrow
but when any of you kind of aware of the
characters beforehand or will you like
everybody read any comic books or stuff
like that I grew up as a as a bit of a
DC nerd so I really had a profound
appreciation for coming onto the show
and I had heard drops of the potential
of anything along the lines of speedy
Arsenal or red arrow it being like just
from the get-go and in the pilot it was
written that he said speedy so it was
just a huge massive Easter Egg for
myself let alone like everybody else
when it came out but you know the three
years was a bit of a long time waiting
for it to happen but I understand why it
all happened that way because of the
trajectory and building up the origins
she needed to go from this point to rock
bottom to build back up again which is
what they've done with like almost
everybody's character really they've
just broken them down to the point where
it they have no choice but to go up or
to the dark like to bring the origins of
these comic book characters to life
speaking of comic books and superheroes
we've got a lot of superhero movies
coming out now for both Marvel and DC
and we've got a lot of TV series I mean
we've got Supergirl starting later in
the year Marvel have got a couple of
they're bound to come up with some more
overload I don't really see it happening
I mean there was that you know that
period of time where there was just a
slew of Batman's and see
coming out I mean it wasn't as many as
this right now but there was still a
period of time and if anything people
were like where did it all go and why
wasn't it good enough I think if
anything the world in reality needs the
morality tale of our superhero stories
we need that I mean especially with the
things that are going on today I mean we
need that sense of hope and you know do
the right thing and wherever you can
protect people who need protecting and
you know it's very inspirational for me
yeah it's a very good message to be
putting out there I mean aside from the
villains and stuff and what they're
doing I wouldn't tell anybody here to go
become Malcolm Merlyn and kill 503
people but I would say totally you know
if you wanted to protect people and like
I'm not saying suit up either but people
can do that in their own ways like we
can all stick together be protective and
and work as a human connected unit talk
about threats enough BAM off see a
comic-con what's it like seeing people
dressed up sin that your characters are
from the TV show everything like that I
actually went to a Comic Con in Atlantic
City last weekend and for the first time
I saw a cosplay version of speedy with
my haircut everything like perfect like
right after the finale it was the day
after the finale aired and then that
happened and she was all the way in the
back of the panel and I could just see
it from the corner of my eye and I just
told her to stand up and I saw her
outfit and I started crying look the
whole crowd because it was just the
coolest thing that's ever happened I
mean I mean it's pretty pretty cool I I
get obsessed with it I'm sure all of us
like I mean your outfit hers is insane
um that mask is amazing I mean I I love
the whole like calming costume designers
work from our own like she's I mean
she's amazing she does such an amazing
job and she also asked me like you know
as a as a pointer I mean because I'm
gonna grow up in Japan so they asked me
like is that really like you know
truthful or like what do you think and
she research about and and she's it's
really nice you know and it's yeah I
really love my car
like she was just finishing her fitting
for the first time I was just about to
try mine on for the first time and I
just remember seeing her it was like oh
what no damn that's gonna be way cooler
than mine and I was waiting like you
know after I finish fitting I was like
watching like from like you know from
the DC Universe that you'd be excited to
see an arrow I always bring it whenever
I could I've had that question quite a
few times today in the last couple weeks
and just pertaining to all that the
movies that are being made and stuff
like that in a comic book world it's
also taking aside from the TV shows
because we had the Suicide Squad and
these things inside of it our guests we
were going really heavily into that for
a minute
and then I mean something must have come
down from DC or some some higher up
above that said no you must ceased and
desist because we're gonna make it into
a movie and we can't have anybody spoil
that idea and we did get to see that
little like pigtail and Argus uniform
and the little treat of a Harlequin and
then it just got ripped away so if we
could actually have Harlequin on the
show that be amazing but it's never
gonna happen
what would you like to see going ahead
for speed you know your superhero
character and would you like to see
Stephen return as green I mean I think I
think that Thea would very much
appreciate having her brother back in
her life even though she's very happy
that he's running off with the woman of
his dreams right now he's very happy but
I think she definitely needs him too and
for her future in season 4 man I just
yeah I hope that she keeps wearing I
cost him as much as possible and maybe
gets a yellow one or the Cape or
something I don't know
do you think we'll see more crossover
episodes with the flash as well would
you like to do some more I would love to
do that stuff but the writers love to
keep us all very much in the dark and
they don't really want to tell me much
about it I mean obviously there wasn't
anything of me in season 3 the crossing
over but there's a bunch of
possibilities especially now that the
legends of tomorrow and everything like
that there's always the options and
stuff but again
like they I didn't even know what my
suit looked like until I tried it on and
I mean I'm just teasing about the
yellowcake
I'm just really wanting it they have not
confirmed the scripts uh god days before
we start shooting like we're probably
gonna get a passerby episode and we're
probably gonna get we start shooting
season 4 July 13th I'm gonna go ahead
and ballpark saying that I'm not gonna
see the script to the 10th which
character wins I would probably lose I'm
a smallest well we already know now we
come on of course she wins she wins in
the costume and she wins in life so
where he's gonna end up all back because
it seems to be about 10 minutes outside
starting the show it's like go Starling
city and then I bet that central I gotta
go through the League of Assassins is a
it's steeped in middle the Middle East
somewhere so that's where it is it's
just a really fast jet I think on the
subject of Harley Quinn obviously
there's been a lot of debate lately
about the alleged under-representation
of female heroes in the Marvel Universe
and some of the DC franchises I'm
curious for you guys how you feel about
that if you have any thoughts on that
and how shows like arrow are going about
redressing that balance um that's that's
actually a really good question because
one thing that makes me so honored to be
on this show is being able to do a
justification of this characters arc as
a female and as an empowered woman I
mean she just gets beaten down by by
everybody in her life whether it be the
males or the females is everybody in her
life has just been lying to her
untrustworthy all that and she honed
into something inside of that like
herself and it's becoming what she is
becoming and it's very very amazing to
be able to represent that and it's I
think a lot of the girls in our show
have been pulling that stuff out really
hard like Katie Cassidy's character has
gone through so much and now just come
out the other end like a very strong
woman
and I have very high hopes for the
future for for women being empowered in
television and in movies I think that
Harlequin could be a great one as as
like crazy sexy supervillain but take it
away from just you know her being sexy
and actually just being strong and
powerful
I think that's usually what should be
pushed out there far more than pumping
up the breasts and showing her ass like
let's actually show her mind or what she
gives physically capable of following on
from that question
we saw the backlash against Mad Max fury
road for a lot of people saying it was
too feminist
we've still got a long way to go at all
I haven't seen it yet but that made me
so mad hear that I mean I I guess I have
no I've never seen it I don't have any
opinion on it yet other than the fact
that what is wrong with some guys out
there saying that like I just don't
understand how how did the conversation
all of a sudden just get reversed like
what's now there's there's male
activists all of a sudden like okay it's
fine it's great congratulations
I recently went back and re-watch the
pilot episode of arrow and it's amazing
just how far each character has come and
I know that this season there was a
flashback to when all he was supposedly
still on the islands and he came and saw
you killed your drug dealer how was it
playing a younger fear again like does
it mean you've all such good character
option one to the finale like it's been
been a huge arc especially for Thea in
the season three but really going back
was it was a bit painful for me to be
honest because I've I mean I I don't
blame people like for typecasting I
understand it but I just feel it felt
like through a trajectory in my career I
was always typecast as a little sister
of somebody and then also a [ __ ] for a
while or like some type of like rich
girl wearing a school uniform I mean
that was the exact same school uniform I
wore in the USA it was really weird
really awkward about it but it's fine
so going back into that thing was just
it was just like haven't I proven that
I'm that this is not who I am
I should not be represented as that but
it was nice to be able to show I was an
interesting control yeah it was nice to
be able to show the contrast between the
two and and prove that and also to show
everybody the fact that I look way
better with short hair than long hair I
mean personally I watch Gotham all the
time it's actually pretty crazy how many
people I've worked with that are
attached in Gotham now legends of
tomorrow and the flash like I worked
with drew a bunch of times
Dominic Purcell have worked with like
just kind of crazy awesome little small
world we have up here but it's it's
amazing I ran into him a few weeks ago
actually at there's the efference and
yeah we were just chatting about it how
crazy it is it's just so it's awesome
but this is your run third CW show
obviously Gossip Girl BOC what is it
about the network's it's not just
yourself off see Katie Cassidy came from
Gossip Girl supernatural what is it
about the network they thought keeps the
whole debility news like young Hollywood
actors I don't know I they just like to
use as I'm not complaining about it
whatsoever I'm very happy to be
gainfully employed whenever they ask for
it
I mean this is definitely my favorite
thing that they've ever asked for me to
do and I'm absolutely honor to be a part
of the CW kind of niche I mean if I fit
that mold keep me in that mold guys I'm
taking half of a in terms of your
characters going season for Thea and
katana especially usually quite serious
characters we've been told that arrow
season 4 is going to take on a lighter
tone much like the flash can you guys
put in details on what's going to happen
with the dark characters like the katana
going forward but they're both very
talented actresses and they'll go with
that flow I think if they were to take a
lighter tone where would you like to see
your captor go in that direction
personally I mean this is all this
personal opinion because again I have no
idea what's happening in season 4
yeah like literally no idea other than
the fact that I'm gonna be in it that's
all I know I I hope that we get to see
some type of effects from the Lazarus
think that would be really awesome some
type of just whatever and whether it be
good or bad and I hope that you know if
people are starting like I think that
the stories are starting to come to a
really like cool calming and almost
everyone's drama is kind of being
resolved so maybe there is like you know
a period of time where everyone can
actually just be happy for a second and
then it'll probably get ruined in a
couple episodes but talked already about
the importance for your characters to
provide connect interesting role models
and stuff for people watching the show I
mean speedy appeared on more like an
iconic DC cover where he was caught
doing drugs by Green hour in the Green
Lantern I mean how does how do you work
that when you're kind of working on your
characters and stuff that like these
characters mean a lot to a lot of people
never think and it's it's it's it's very
interesting because a lot of the people
come up to me and say they like you
realize that Roy Harper was supposed to
be speedy I'm like yeah that's in one of
the comics but there's also another one
where me or deodorant miss PD so I mean
I hate to say I have done my research
and I do know what I'm talking about
when it comes to this stuff and I get
you know people not thinking that but
it's it's it's interesting coming from
the show cuz there's our writers rope
for the comics and they have a huge
profound love for the stories and they
don't want us to steer away from it but
it's also difficult being on television
being on a network and trying to mix the
two together there's definitely certain
things that are gonna that are going to
be lost a little bit but it's it's nice
to be able to pull out those stops and
prove the actual stories in the pudding
I guess I think what what makes a hero
also very interesting is their
vulnerability that that's what makes
them interesting to watch because
they're I mean how how interesting would
it be of a hero was just this hero all
the time it would lose interest so like
you said like they're gonna do some some
flawed things and you know that's that's
great for the morality part of the story
as like a cautionary aspect of what not
to do and how we can learn from it
especially as heroes
well I'm going back to my friends some
questions about the drug issue in the
flashback it was shown that you were
using drugs but and in the comic book it
was like a big deal do you feel that in
the show I wasn't really sight given
enough point um yes or no I think that
the fact that they showed it was
admirable enough III respect it as a
comic book lover I am like I could take
that but I can understand people not
thinking that it was enough but the
reasons why is because again we work on
the CW we can't just be shoving needles
in people's veins and stuff like that
like it's just not gonna happen on the
network but I think that you know it was
nice how they brought it back around at
this season they just a nice little
refresher and in case you know people
forgot how silly she was back in the day
there you go there's a reminder of just
like a bit of the her trajectory as that
and also yeah I mean it's an interesting
thing it's hard to kind of go through it
though
you